well my initial pitch was pretty simple
and it was really sparked off the idea
of doing something with emotions as
characters because that seemed ripe for
what animation can do you know really
strong opinionated kind of caricatured
characters like Bugs Bunny or Daffy Duck
or whatever it's coupled with watching
my daughter grow up and she had gone
from being a really rambunctious little
goofy kid to being a little more quiet
and in her as an 11 year old and me kind
of mourning the passing of that and
wondering what's going on in her head to
change all that and it was really not
much more than that that I pitched it to
you guys and eventually to John Lasseter
he immediately saw the potential and I
think that's a big thing for us at Pixar
he's like you're not pitching a fully
finished project because we all know
it's going to grow in very small
increments and be discovered along the
way so from then it was working with a
couple other writers and evolving it to
a place where it was pretty broken not
on purpose we were trying to make it
work but it it kind of got to a middle
place where it wasn't really working
that's when meg came on and really
helped us find the structure of what
that was what was broken about it I mean
obviously you you weren't responding to
it then you you knew what you wanted to
do but you weren't getting there but
what was what was the major thing that
was giving you trouble one of the things
that was what we do is we write write so
Pete and we wrote a script and we
assemble a story team and an art
department to start trying to visualize
it and what I noticed was we do this at
Pixar so every three three or four
months we'd do a screening of these
story reels and when you judge it as a
movie and so forth and what would happen
you know every time we do that we get
Brad Bird and Andrew Stanton and John
Lasseter in the group to kind of give
notes and it all say it's what a great
idea
and in a second in a second screening
what a great idea this is and no one who
was saying the word movie and we were we
were thinking like God even if they said
it's a bad movie we'd be happy like we
couldn't we couldn't get it from out of
this concept idea which is it we it was
it was this really cool simple but yet
beautiful and complex idea and it just
took a lot of wrestling and I think we
were struggling with well how does it
even work functionally what memories and
Islands and the geography of it was in a
weird way impeding the structure some
right so yeah so I just took a lot of
pounding it out to get it in shape and
then and then bringing Meg on and you
just had some really great character and
structure observations about who joy
should be and what that threat should be
and that really I don't know broke it
loose somehow one of the sort of
foundational things that was broken
about it was we initially had paired joy
with fear because fear was a very
important part of my junior high school
experience anyway and so we thought oh
that's gonna be some good comedy and and
and it was we had some good stuff but at
the end it didn't amount to anything joy
had to escape from the dump get back to
headquarters to do what and we didn't
have that and that's kind of when I knew
it wasn't working yet that we needed to
restructure the whole thing and it was
during a walk on a weekend at the same
time we knew that this film needed to
move into production we need to start
making it but at the same time I was
like yeah but it just doesn't work and I
realized well okay that maybe I'm a
fraud you know the films I've worked on
or just flukes and I should just quit
because I I've failed and what would I
miss well I miss my house on this you
know coming to work but I guess my
friends I'm gonna miss the most and it
sort of hit me like the friends that I'm
the closest to our friends that I have
had good experiences with but I've had
really bad ones as well I've been sad
along with them suffering the loss of
different people and experiences I've
been angry at them I've been scared for
them and I realized okay the very
subject matter of this movie is the key
to probably the most important thing in
our lives and that's relationship with
each other and that sort of what felt
like an epiphany I called Jonas and
Ronnie del Carmen who's not here is a
co-director and and we said we need to
retool the movie and thankfully instead
of hitting me they said yes they sort of
caught the same so normally I just hit
him and it was about that time that meg
came on so we had this kind of again
ethereal idea of sadness somehow being
important to Joy but we weren't sure
exactly how to dramatize that and Meg
really no no if you have memories about
how some meg were you like the new shot
of energy at the crucial moment bringing
the fresh horses I was I was the fresh
horse I was still like yes we can do
this that's great and they were like ok
wow when Pete told me about wanting to
shift the movie to the connection being
about sadness and that sadness can
actually not be something to avoid but
something that you should understand is
bring his creating connection I I was so
in and I and I really worked towards
that and I kind of thought you know this
is Pete's movie so I kind of felt like
the contractor you know making sure the
walls will stand up right over the over
the film so what are the walls of the
film that make this beautiful movie
stand up and it's joy and what is the
main relationship that she needs to be
in and of course it's Riley but Riley is
really what she's fighting for alright
she's almost the stakes of the movie
she's the heart of the movie but who is
joy in relationship to she's it's got to
be sadness if we want her to learn about
sadness then she needs to be on the road
with sadness and we just started talking
about where joy starts and where does
she finish how is she going to learn
this you know how annoying can send this
be and still love her how annoying can
joy be you know because the trick with
Joy's character is contstantly happy
people are kind of really annoying right
and even as we started to get the movie
up and people were starting to use the
word movie I guess we still had that you
know challenge of Joy's character so
really don't like joy we just don't like
joy because she's kind of like this all
the time you know I can do it so we
talked a lot about even though she's joy
she has to have vulnerability and she
has to be worried and she has to kind of
drop occasionally emotionally herself in
terms of oh like when the islands are
going down she has to be vulnerable so
that when she goes back up to but I can
fix it yes you you go back up with her
and you can feel the that she's working
really hard and her joy so that really
all that stuff started to kind of you
know put it all together into it and it
was really was finding the poles
her character and the stakes of Riley
and how do we how do we show the stakes
as something emotional which I think you
were great explaining the islands I'm
sure you were busy on a whole bunch of
things while they were doing this
Michael scores like a 15 other film
scored one right now at what point were
you brought into this and what time at
what point did you see this I mean I
guess it was when was the first time I
saw this it was you in early to show you
yes we knew we wanted to work together
yeah that's about year and a half or two
years beforehand I mean look the truth
is we're friends so we hang out together
anyway so I'm sort of around the process
and I do get updates and guide pitch to
you while we were in line at Disneyland
yes I pitched you the concept like
there's two months into it yes it was a
long time ago so I'm always around so
it's always ruminating it's always I get
to see the development of it I mean but
what really when I first see a story
real and I get to sit I go up to Pixar
and I sit and I watch the entire movie
it's on storyboards and and that's my
first chance to to feel something it's
my first chance to just watch it and see
how I feel because for me the whole
thing is I need to translate what I'm
feeling to you the audience to Pete to
Jones to make everybody and hopefully
what I'm feeling is what they want
people to feel when they're when they're
when they're watching the film so I went
I watched it I cried which I often do
with Pete's work he's a terrible
terrible man that makes me cry a lot and
and and i went home and i just i just
sat with it for a few days and then i
went to the piano and i wrote what I
felt
you know after thinking about it and I
wrote a 12-minute suite of music which
encompassed all the areas of the film
and and after thinking about them how
did that make me feel and I invited him
and Jonas to come down and and listen to
it and we just sat in my room and and I
just hit play we sat there for 12
minutes well you know which was sort of
torturous for me I'm in the back
just going god I hope that they are
feeling what I was feeling you know but
you can then I mean you're you can Joan
and I are sitting there and we're sort
of look at each other and it was just
you know he totally nailed I think I
just ran over and give you a hug after
he was coming to hit me I was like one
of the great moments of the movie to be
honest cuz it was a it was a bull's-eye
it's almost exactly what you hear that
beginning and even they over the end
credits at the very end it was just so
beautiful and somehow to me it just felt
like I don't know this beautiful lullaby
but that was fun and the mom though I
don't know it just felt it was right
well it was an incredible gift to work
on this film especially as someone who
has kids I you know and and and I have a
15 year old daughter now so being able
to sort of think the things that you
were speaking to what is going on inside
their head being able to sort of express
that in some artistic way was a real
sort of therapeutic cathartic thing for
me as a parent and I didn't realize how
emotional I would get but there were
times when I was working and I literally
had to leave my office I didn't leave
the room because I would just start
crying and I just like why am i crying
what is going on here and I'd have to
walk away and just sit with it for a
while and and I did I was hesitant to
brush it off to not feel it because I
also knew that that's what this whole
movie was about was allowing yourself to
feel this sadness you know and it wasn't
always sadness in the way of I mean it
sorry can't even explain sometimes why I
was feeling that way but things were
coming out that I hadn't expected at all
was there a part of the music that was
the most troublesome for you as far as
getting the right tone or yes we worked
a lot on the ending you know I mean we
you know you don't obviously you know
you I guess you'd I get I personally
would love everyone we're leaving the
theater crying because if anyone's ever
you know watched a lot of my stuff as
sad but I
III I think the hardest thing was the
ending and getting that tone right
because you wanted to make sure that
people had enough time to sit and
experience that sadness and and feel it
and not then just turn on
diamond and start telling him jokes you
know right away it was so important to
have that time to feel it so that was
something we we struggled with weight a
bit back and forth how do we how do we
can address picture yeah at the same
time we were kind of struggling with
that yes interesting though because for
my reaction to it was that it's a very
subtle score and I were you deliberately
I mean I know you're trying to make us
feel things but at the same time right
you can get too heavy with but here's
the thing you've on that balance here's
the thing about music is it's a lot like
consoling somebody if you're with a
friend and they just had a terrible
experience you are not going to sit
there and you're not gonna do that
you're going to go put your arms around
them you're gonna hold them you going to
speak very very softly and simply and
just be there for them so that's how the
approach I felt for the music I just
wanted it to be there for for Riley for
her and to be as simple and understated
as possible and you know there are
moments of course where it goes a little
nuts here in there depending you know on
the action but on a whole I just I just
wanted it to feel simple and an intimate
that's amazing because that's the theme
of the movie I love that you know just
be there just be there with them where
they are so